well folks another tragic accident where
an individual who just happened to be
critical of Russian President Vladimir
Putin has very sadly
and very accidentally
fall into his death out of a hotel
window
it's almost like this is an epidemic in
Russia by mere coincidence people who
criticize Vladimir Putin fall out of
Windows sometimes in an act of taking
their own life as it is reported so
here's what we have and yes it is
another one of these stories it's really
December 27 2022 today this isn't a
repeat of the story like this from two
months ago or six months ago or whatever
Russian meat magnate this is the Sausage
King of Russia apparently I'm not even
exaggerating that Russian meat magnate
who criticized Putin's War dies after a
hotel fall
a Russian sausage magnate who briefly
criticized Russia's invasion of Ukraine
as died after falling from the third
floor window of a luxury hotel in India
Pavel antov was a member of Putin's
United Russia party and a
multi-millionaire having founded one of
the country's largest sausage makers he
was reportedly on a trip to celebrate
his upcoming 66th birthday when he was
found lying in a pool of blood outside
the hotel PSI International and rayagada
in the southern state of odisha an
unnamed police official told India's
NDTV news outlet they suspect he took
his own life because he was depressed
about the death of his friend who was
found dead at the same Hotel
hmm Vladimir bidenov was found
unconscious in his hotel room on
Thursday surrounded by empty wine
bottles antof was the founder of
Vladimir standard a major meat producer
had an income of just under 230 million
dollars a year
in July you posted a story on his
WhatsApp criticizing Russia's missile
attacks on Kiev as terrorism
he was referring to reports of a girl
that was pulled from Rubble after a
house was shelled shortly afterward he
apologized for the post and said it was
posted by someone else someone got into
his WhatsApp and sent a message he said
he was a supporter of the president and
my country's Patriot and shared the
goals of the invention The Invasion
um
the Russia Consul General in Calcutta
said there was no foul play so listen
was there foul play or not I don't know
but it's very strange I mean even that
story
he was at the same hotel where another
Russian died and he was so depressed of
that by that
that he took his own life it's very
strange and of course this endlessly
expanded Wiki article 2022 Russian
businessmen mystery deaths you might
remember in January we covered the death
of Leonard Shulman uh we later covered
there's so many of these I don't
remember all of the ones that we covered
more uh I believe we covered the Pavel
chelnikov death
um maybe also the Nikolai mashagi and
that so anyway you can look at all of
these and each is very very strange
suffered a stroke fell out of a hotel
window a hospital window all these
different things it's very very
suspicious and I know many of you will
email me and you will say David what do
you mean suspicious these people are
obviously being murdered
I I understand remember the whole point
here is no one's really supposed to
believe the story that's told like you
and I we see oh it's been reported that
they tripped on a remote in their hotel
room and fell out the window onto six
knives David that's not believable
that's the point okay I can't say all of
these are murders but some of them are
obviously murders okay the point is that
the explanations not be believable
because it's how you communicate they'll
kill you that's the entire point and so
it's not
who thinks we're going to believe these
stories it's that's the whole point they
tell unbelievable stories and here is
yet another suspicious one put it on the
list of suspicious will we ever know
which ones are what they are said to be
and which ones are the murders uh we may
not we may not but it is happening again